the most astounding place i've ever been
is the mosquito rainforest in honduras
i've done archaeological field work all
over the world so i thought i knew what
to expect
venturing into the jungle but i was
wrong
for the first time in my life i might
add
first of all it's freezing it's 90
degrees but you're soaking wet from the
humidity
and the canopy of trees is so thick that
sunlight never reaches the surface
you can't get dry immediately i knew
that i hadn't brought enough clothing
that first night i kept feeling things
moving underneath my hammock
unknown creatures brushing and poking
against the thin nylon fabric
and i could barely sleep through all the
noise the jungle is loud it's shockingly
loud it's like
being downtown in a bustling city
as the night wore on i became
increasingly frustrated with my
sleeplessness
knowing i had a full day ahead when i
finally got up at dawn
my sense of unseen things was all too
real
there were hoof prints paw prints linear
snake tracks
everywhere and what's even more shocking
we saw those same animals in the
daylight and they were completely
unafraid of us
they had no experience with people they
had no reason to be for afraid
as i walked towards the undocumented
city my reason for being there
i realized that this was the only place
that i'd ever been
where i didn't see a single shred of
plastic
that's how remote it was perhaps it's
surprising to learn that there are still
places on our planet
that are so untouched by people but it's
true
there are still hundreds of places where
people haven't stepped for centuries
or maybe forever
it's an awesome time to be an
archaeologist
we have the tools and the technology to
understand our planet like never before
and yet we're running out of time the
climate crisis
threatens to destroy our ecological and
cultural patrimony
i feel an urgency to my work that i
didn't feel 20 years ago
how can we document everything before
it's too late
i was trained as a traditional
archaeologist using methodologies that
have been around since
the 50s that all changed in july of 2009
in michoacan mexico i was studying the
ancient prepa
empire which is the lesser known but
equally important contemporary of the
aztec
two weeks earlier my team had documented
an unknown settlement
so we were painstakingly mapping
building foundations
by hand hundreds of them
basic archaeological protocols to find
the edge of a settlement
so you know what you're dealing with my
graduate students convinced me to do
just that so i grabbed a couple of clif
bars some water
a walkie and i set out alone on foot
expecting to encounter the edge just a
few minutes
a few minutes passed and then an hour
finally i reached the other side of the
malpais oh
there were ancient building foundations
all the way across
it's a city oh [ __ ]
it's a city
turns out that this seemingly small
settlement
was actually an ancient urban
megalopolis
26 square kilometers in size with as
many
building foundations as modern-day
manhattan
an archaeological settlement so large
that it would take me
decades to survey fully the entire rest
of my career
which was exactly how i didn't want to
spend the entire
rest of my career
sweating exhausted placating
stressed out graduate students
tossing scraps of pb j sandwiches to
feral dogs which
is pointless by the way because mexican
dogs really don't
like peanut butter
just the thought of it bored me to tears
so i returned home to colorado and i
poked my head through a colleague's door
dude there's got to be a better way
he asked if i'd heard of this new
technology called lidar light detection
arranging
i looked it up lidar involves shooting a
dense grid of laser pulses from an
airplane
to the ground surface what you end up
with is a high resolution scan
of the earth's surface and everything on
it it's not an image
but instead it's a dense
three-dimensional cloud of points
we had enough money in the scan so we
did just that
the company went to mexico they flew the
lidar and they sent back the data
over the next several months i learned
to practice digital deforestation
filtering away trees brush and other
vegetation
to reveal the ancient cultural landscape
below
when i looked at my first visualization
i began to cry
which i know comes as quite a shock to
you given how manly i must see
in just 45 minutes of flying the lidar
had collected the same amount of data
as what would have taken decades by hand
every house foundation
building road and pyramid incredible
detail
representing the lives of thousands of
people
who lived and loved and died in these
spaces
and what's more the quality of the data
wasn't comparable to traditional
archaeological research
it was much much better i knew that this
technology would change the entire
field of archaeology in the coming years
and it did
our work came to the attention of a
group of filmmakers who were searching
for a legendary lost city in honduras
they failed in their quest but they
instead documented an
unknown culture now buried under a
pristine
wilderness rainforest using lidar
i agreed to help interpret their data
which is how i found myself
deep in that mosquito jungle plastic
free and filled with curious animals
our goal was to verify that the
archaeological features we identified in
our lidar
were actually there on the ground and
they were
11 months later i returned with a crack
team of archaeologists
sponsored by the national geographic
society and the honduran government
in a month we excavated over 400 objects
from what we now call the city of the
jaguar
we felt a moral and ethical
responsibility to protect the site as it
was
but in the short time that we were there
things inevitably changed
the tiny gravel bar where we first
landed our helicopter
was gone the brush had been cleared away
and the trees removed
to create a large landing zone for
several helicopters at once
without it after just one rainy season
the ancient canals that we had seen in
our lidar scan
were damaged or destroyed in the eden i
described
soon had a large clearing central camp
lights and an outdoor chapel
in other words despite our best efforts
to protect the site as it was
things changed our initial lidar scan
of this city of the jaguar is the only
record of this place as it existed
just a few years ago
and broadly speaking this is a problem
for archaeologists
we can't study an area without changing
it somehow
and regardless the earth is changing
archaeological
sites are destroyed history is lost
just this year we watched in horror as
the notre dame cathedral went up in
flames
the iconic spire collapsed and the roof
was all but destroyed
miraculously the art historian andrew
talin and colleagues
scanned the cathedral in 2010 using
lidar
at the time their goal was to understand
how the building was constructed
now their lidar skin is the most
comprehensive record of the cathedral
and it will prove invaluable in the
reconstruction
they couldn't have anticipated the fire
or how their skin would be used
but we're lucky to have it we take for
granted that our cultural and ecological
patrimony will be around forever
it won't organizations like sciarc and
virtual wonders
are doing incredible work to record the
world's historic monuments
but nothing similar exists for the
earth's landscapes
we've lost 50 percent of our rainforests
we lose 18 million acres of forest every
year and rising sea levels
will make cities countries and
continents
completely unrecognizable unless we have
a record of these places
no one in the future will know they
existed
if the earth is the titanic we've struck
the iceberg
everyone's on deck and the orchestra is
playing
the climate crisis threatens to destroy
our cultural and ecological patrimony
within decades but sitting on our hands
and doing nothing
is not an option shouldn't we save
everything we can on the lifeboats
looking at my scans from honduras and
mexico
it's clear that we need to scan scan
scan
now as much as possible while we still
can
that's what inspired the earth archive
an unprecedented scientific
effort to light our skin the entire
planet
starting with areas that are most
threatened
its purpose is threefold number one
create a baseline record of the earth as
it exists today
to more effectively mitigate the climate
crisis
to measure change you need two sets of
data a
and and after right now we don't have a
high resolution before data set
for much of the planet so we can't
measure change
and we can't evaluate which of our
current efforts to combat the climate
crisis
are making a positive impact
number two create a virtual planet
so that any number of scientists can
study our earth today
archaeologists like me can look for
undocumented settlements
ecologists can study tree size forest
composition and age
geologists can study hydrology faults
disturbance possibilities are endless
number three preserve a record of the
planet for our grandchildren's
grandchildren
so they can reconstruct and study lost
cultural patrimony
in the future as science and technology
advance
they'll apply new tools algorithms
even ai to light our scans done today
and ask questions that we can't
currently conceive of
like notre dame we can't imagine
how these records will be used but we
know that they'll be critically
important
the earth archive is the ultimate gift
to future generations
because the truth be told i won't live
long enough to see its full impact
and neither will you that's exactly why
it's worth doing
the earth archive is a bet on the future
of humanity
it's about that together collectively
as people and as scientists
that will face the climate crisis and
that we'll choose to do the right thing
not just for us today but to honor those
who came before us
and to pay it forward to future
generations
who will carry on our legacy
thank you